well thousands of firefighters as you
say k battling hundreds of blazes
luckily no deaths but dozens of people
injured we're in an area north of lisbon
that experienced some of those worst
fire fires
at the moment a little bit of a reprieve
because the temperatures dipped but
we're expecting temps of over 40 degrees
up to 46 perhaps in this area and let me
just show you why it's such a big
problem there are villages and
communities dotted around this country
north of lisbon look at that house just
escaped the flames
probably due to
real efforts from firefighters and the
homeowners soaking the area in water
this isn't just an issue as you were
saying okay for portugal it's across
europe climate change is helping to
drive the conditions that lead to
wildfires officials in europe are saying
that this continent could experience one
of its worst years because the heat
events are getting worse the drought
events are getting worse and that
combines in a toxic combination really
to extend fire seasons and misery for
communities and there's much worse to
come here and of course up into spain
france and into the united kingdom later
in the week with temperatures of well
over 40 degrees expected